[Musique]
je très fort
c'est toujours et je jouais avant
longtemps
[Musique]
ou alors aujourd'hui pour rire toi je me
garde
on est à la maison on n'est pas loin du
parc monceau pas beaucoup conduire à
paris c'est très compliqué alors
aujourd'hui je vous parlais de
l'écosystème samsung on va parler
réfrigérateur on va parler lave linge
on n'a pas parlé harry potter avec
barbara qui va vous regardez vite faire
il faut que tu regardes remo harry
potter c'est mon fils rouges
l'oms est regardé le premier épisode
d'harry potter faut avoir suivi parce
qu'on en a déjà parlé il ya quelques
jours à londres elle avait jamais
regarder harry potter shame on you
maintenant il ya deuxième affaire mais
alors pas donc aujourd'hui on va parler
de l'écosystème complet de san suu on va
parler je réfrigérateurs lave-linge
télévision a pas parlé du produit en lui
même on va parler de ce que vient
souffler samsung est en gros comment ils
vont considérer tous ces produits pour
les rentrer dans votre intérieur et vous
allez voir c'est franchement très
intéressant
[Musique]
et
bonsoir à jouer là je pars sur un zéro
pour la la taille de l'écran est hyper
impressionnant 90% du terrain sur fifa
11 ou contre le pérou assez la machine
un petit et plein de gens saluent alors
tu peux me dire qui tu es bonjour
aurélien moi je m'appelle matthieu
lanier je suis responsable du marketing
pour les activités électroménager et
télé audio ok ça lui mathieu alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui est ce
que tu peux nous expliquer ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui tous eu alors
aujourd'hui dans ce lieu
paris à côté du parc monceau où on
présente les nouvelles gammes et
l'électroménager pour 2019
sachant que
toutes égales télé sont intégralement
renouvelées et sur l'électroménager
on présente aussi sa sous un oeil un
petit peu expérience avec
un peu des mots pour expliquer en quoi
nos produits ou importés des usages qui
sont un petit peu différent et en quoi
ils vont se différencier de ce qui
existe déjà
la dernière fois il ya des échos on a un
écran là on a un écran la teste ses
écrans vont nous apporter de notre
convoi qui s'attaque vraiment la déco en
fait alors en fait ça c'est important le
premier critère d'achat d'un téléviseur
ça reste la qualité d'image donc on a
plein de petites des mots dans ce
bâtiment qui parle de la qualité d'image
est ce qui explique en quoi on l'a fait
progresser mais c'est vrai que des
choses
une des choses qui est important c'est
de d'essayer d'effacer la télé ou la
télé quand elle marche pas ça reste un
écran noir
nous on a inventé des solutions pour
essayer de cacher ou d'intégrer mieux le
téléviseur dans son intérieur
quand on a par exemple un produit qui va
être fixée au mur on va prendre une
photo de son téléviseur est
automatiquement cette photo elle va être
transféré via l'application smart things
à la télé hong kong a recalculé le le
royal la typologie de décors de papier
peint qu'on a derrière de façon à
essayer de cacher l'écran dans ce papier
peint et qui après on peut le
personnaliser à personnaliser les
couleurs ont pas rajouté des choses un
petit message météo on peut rajouter
leur gros tueront pas télé quand elle
était belle intrigués
oui assez intelligente avec des infos
pratiques exactement est unique parce
qu'évidemment on a tous des intérieurs
un peu différent comme nous le voyons
dans des petits écrans du cul leica dc
4k usd dont 6 et pas seulement les
grands écrans les moniteurs et la
sanomat
ça ne souffre aucune aide l'expertisé
samsung au service d'une expérience en
ligne ça c'est plutôt cool et en termes
d'écrans ya de quoi faire la deuxième
chose c'est qu'on a des télés qui
deviennent des cadres photos dont
lausanne se ferait exactement donc le
frame en fait on en est déjà à la
troisième génération
là on a un lancement du frame qui est
prévue pour début mai prochain dont le
présente dans cet endroit
le concept du frame c'est de faire d'une
telle est une oeuvre d'art donc quand ça
en fait on a un téléviseur dont on peut
personnaliser les bords avec soit des
bords noirs soient des bords blancs un
débord enchaîne père ou prochaine font
ces ambiances un peu vent gay et puis on
a une accroche murale ultrafin on a un
boîtier déporté le boîtier bois one
connect qui permet d'être cachés
ailleurs une télécommande unique
bluetooth pour piloter ses contenus et
puis un petit câble un petit câble en
fibre optique ultra fins qui va
permettre à la fois d'alimenter les
téléviseurs les puis de transférer tous
les signaux l'information directement
dans ta formation ça ça permet de cacher
complètement son téléviseur et on a un
magasin de d'oeuvres d'art ce qu'on
appelle l'art tu sors où on peut accéder
à peu près mille deux cents oeuvres
d'art qui sont en location pour à peu
près 5 euros par mois et on a une
troisième série qui n'est pas représenté
aujourd'hui mais qui arrivera dans le
courant du mois de mai avec un
téléviseur qui lui est pensé comme un
objet design
alors petit cocorico qui a été design et
par les designers français que sur les
frères bouroullec qui ont trait non pas
un téléviseur mais un objet de design
un objet design iconique pour tous ceux
qui sont des fous de beaux objets et là
le téléviseur il va s'intégrer dans
votre salon comme une
renard comme quelque chose qu'on va être
content de montrer avec là aussi ce mode
ambiant des ces différentes ambiances
sur l'écran arrière donc là ça va on va
être sur un très très bel objet avec des
tailles de 43 à 55 pouces
quelque chose qui va vraiment ressembler
à tout sauf à un téléviseur face au
magnifique tes pompes et bobo boulot
quand même elles sont super prêt pompe
j'ai trouvé ça vous elles sont pas
connectés celle là c'est pas de la
chaussure comme ça et donc là on est
dans l'univers plutôt la machine à
l'arrêt c'est alors que là on est on se
trouve dans la pièce dans la buanderie
de la maison pièce est donc qu'est ce
qu'on montre on montre en fait la
technologie coupe grey c'est la réponse
que samsung apporte un problématique qui
est féru des cif c'est fastidieux ça
prend du temps et on essaye en fait avec
ces technologies là de réduire le temps
de lavage non pas seulement sur un
programme rapide parce que tout le monde
a après un rapide dans son lave-linge
oui ça existe simplement le désavantage
après un rapide c'est que ça consomme
beaucoup d'énergie et en plus de ça
s'apprend pas forcément soin du linge ou
alors c'est souvent qu'on a des
programmes qui va être des programmes 15
minutes 30 minutes
c'est plus un rafraîchissement du linge
qu'un vrai lavage d'accord donc nous on
va essayer de remédier à ça qu'est ce
qu'on a fait on a créé un espèce de
double tambour avec une technologie
qu'on appelle quick drive tambour il va
nous proposer deux mouvements un
mouvement en fait classique du tambour
et puis on a on voit ici le dessin d'une
espèce délice au fond elle a tourné dans
le sens inverse du tambour et qui va
permettre de créer une action mécanique
plus énergique de façon à gagner jusqu'à
simple 50% de temps sur absolument tous
les lavages
on a un produit qui intègre cette petite
rappaz doit aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se
passe quand on amène le panier de linge
sale et qu'on charge ça souvent quand on
retourne sur ses parodies et merde la
chaussette
oubliant qu'il attendait de la chaussée
des leçons qu'il faut laver les jeux
vient de lancer le truc horrible
vêtements de sport m a oublié de même
s'il faut absolument la vessie non il en
reste donc en fait on a un petit bouton
pause
d'accord c'est un peu comme un lecteur
blu ray ont fait pose automatiquement le
tambour s'arrête d'abord on va ouvrir la
trappe qu'on va mettre son linge on leur
ferme
on aura pu sur play et le lavage je veux
continuer on a aujourd'hui un réservoir
donc là en fait un réservoir qui
permettent de mettre la lessive ou qui
permet de mettre l'adoucissant est
automatiquement quand on met le linge il
ya une pesée du linge qui est faite
automatiquement par la mort par lola par
le lave-linge absolument
et puis en mesurant avec des capteurs le
ce qu'on appelle le terme technique
c'est la turbidité de l'eau que l'eau
est plus ou moins claires et quel est le
degré de salissure en parlant du poids
en fonction de ça il va plus ou moins
dosé de la lessive de façon à ce que là
aussi on met pas trop déçu parce qu'en
fait tous les français ont tendance à
toujours mettre aux charges
on veut tellement propre
donc là en fait on est devant le familia
ben ouais alors le familia oeuvre
sait on pourrait considérer que c'est un
vieux produit chez nous parce qu'il a
été lancé en mai 2010 est donc en fait à
perdre la particularité de ce
réfrigérateur
c'est que c'est le seul produit
électroménager au monde qui est évolutif
gratuitement pour ses utilisateurs
donc là on présente la version 4.0
qu'est ce qui change
en fait ce qui change c'est l'interface
et le magasin d'applications le concept
c'est quoi c'est déjà d'avoir un bon et
un grand frigo
donc c'est notre frigo on met en a en
outre là on a 500 550 litres à peu près
de capacité donc c'est un grand et bon
produit au delà de ça on essaie de
proposer un usage un peu différent on a
quoi on a un écran 21 pouces verticale
en full hd
on a une application sous tyson et on a
donc un magasin d'applications avec un
certain nombre d'usagers ce produit va
être connecté je vais la voir sur mon
smartphone avec l'application sporting
et puis quand je vais être dans mon
magasin je vais faire mes courses e chez
moi en fait je vais pouvoir voir ce
qu'il a dans les faits j'attends donc ça
je vais l'avoir en permanence visible
sur mon smartphone et quand je fais mes
couches bédié chuté ce qui me reste du
beurre et chinoises de la confiture ça
je vois la vision et j'aurai un
permanence
la dernière photo qui aura été prise
puisque à chaque fois qu'on ferme et
qu'on ouvre le réfrigérateur
là tu as des petites caméras et en fait
ces caméras là à chaque fois qu'on ouvre
et qu'on ferme la porte on prend une
photo et donc on aura sa d'accès une
fois que j'ai ça derrière je vais à la
possibilité de mettre mes des aliments
de les reconnaître
donc là je vais dire j'ai mis une salade
en l'occurrence des mines jaquettes de
jeux vidéo mais on dira que c'est une
salade et puis derrière je vais
paramétrer la date de péremption
j'ai ma liste de courses donc ma liste
de courses au lieu de l'oublier le
morceau de papier que j'ai préparé le
matin sur le plan de faille dans la
cuisine est en permanence dans mon
smartphone est en permanence se
réactualiser je vais également avoir des
partenariats avec marmitons qui vont
permettre d'avoir accès à mes recettes
commerciales
on a également un haut parleur et de la
voix donc quand je les fais à mes
recettes
je vais lui dire grâce à la scie à
l'assistant vocal bixby puis de biscuits
met en pause
je sais ma recette bizzbee continue
limmois la recette mais les volumes plus
fort - fort et donc quand on est en
train de préparer sa recette dans la
cuisine avec les mains prises
on peut tout contrôler et à la voix sur
son application aux marines c'est
également un produit de divertissement
donc le divertissement ça va passer pour
la capacité à afficher en mirroring le
contenu de son téléviseur directement
dans le sur le familial et donc je veux
avoir la diffusion de ma télé en live
sur mon réfrigérateur
donc pendant le match de foot quand je
vais chercher les bières ça m'évite de
rater le but
bon je me suis levé pour les coups que
j'ai accès à internet donc en ayant
accès à internet va ça va me permettre
d'aller d'aller sur youtube par exemple
provisionner les bonnes vidéos du menu
des tests de matériel
j'ai un calendrier donc j'ai la
synchronisation de mon agenda sur le
calendrier de mon agenda mais également
de celui de la famine en fait il
vraiment le long centre de ta maison
main sur le coeur de ta maison qui est
ici ou unifier tous les objets euros on
essaye de on essaye de réinventer le
réfrigérateur
oui de leur pensée comme n'importe quel
smartphone on évolue on fait évoluer
l'interface on fait évoluer
l'intelligence de la même façon on
travaille sur les applications pour
apporter de plus en plus d' usage est
quelqu'un qui a acheté la famille diab
il ya deux ans
gratuitement il a la possibilité de
recevoir ces aides d'état
deux ans après je sais le flou voilà n'a
pas trop de cash est là quand même
mais sympa ton petit truc mais c'était
laisser un animal bon voilà c'est tout
pour aujourd'hui alors hop je te refais
une petite voiture pro reparlera bien
évidemment certains ya plein de choses à
vous raconter sur les produits samsung
sur l'écosystème samsung
la soirée se termine je suis le dernier
ici j'en profite
avec mon petit bolide qui juste la
variété qu'on s'amuse comme on peut
donc voilà donc je vous invite bien
évidemment rester connecté à vous
abonner parce qu on a parlé beaucoup de
samsung il ya plein de choses à dire
dessus et je vous fais des bisous à très
bientôt
prenez soin de vous et soyez sages ciao